really heard this a bunch of times which
is a lot of times as an entrepreneur
you just need to be in the market you
need to be in the game and even if your
current thing's not working
if you are aware of these like
inflection points you're the perfect
person to just shift over i feel like i
can rule the world i know i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back all right
we had a good episode well i think we
talked about a lot of stuff what do we
talk about we talk about the zapier for
sound we talked about
yeah we talked about the opportunity now
that college athletes can make money
what are the business opportunities
around that that just opened up
and i think if you're interested in
software i think sean you actually gave
like one of the
one of the better ideas in the last
three months that we discussed so that's
kind of interesting
we talked about a new company that's
creating a search engine for company
documents it sounds boring but it's
actually could be quite a big business
what else did we talk about
the last thing is we talked about this
business model idea of basically
go take the r d that the big companies
do and that they make custom software
for themselves like the starbucks mobile
app or the domino's
pizza ordering app and then make that
available to all the mom and pop so we
did a bunch of examples of of that and
where the opportunities might be
all right listen up let us know how uh
and how you liked it
my twitter is the sam parr then sean's
is
sean vp all right what's going on
yo um i'm in new york i um
i had a hell of a week but i'm here tell
the story
so i leave uh so i'm driving
so i got this like nice car and i love
driving it
i i'm living in new york for a few
months i wanted to do that long drive
because
it's fun for me in my car i'm all ready
i got my dog everything
i get 15 hours into the drive i get out
of my hotel room
and i have two spare keys on the same
ring because you can't leave one of
these fancy keys in the car otherwise
the car won't
shut right so when i go to the hotel i
put them on this
on one ring and then when i get in the
car i separate them
i'm on the phone my mom first thing in
the morning just saying what's up put my
keys both of them on the roof for a
second
get in the car start the car drive off
60 minutes later i stopped for gas and i
go
shoot the car's telling me that i can't
start it because the keys aren't here
what the heck
where are the keys turns out i left him
on the roof
60 miles back drove off and i go back to
find him over many hours of searching
for them
someone ran over both the key fobs so
you actually found the destroyed team i
found the destroyed
parts and i had a locked bike
my like nice bike was locked to the roof
along with my thule
like rack was locked in there i find
those keys thankfully otherwise i was
gonna have to call the welder to like
weld my bike off and like
pop this lock open and i find those keys
but my fobs my 800
i think they're 800 or a thousand
they're expensive completely smashed to
bits
i call mercedes they tow my car this is
on a thursday they go we are not going
to get a new key
in until thursday so
obviously [__] you got you you're
supposed to be in new york you're stuck
in tennessee
i'm driving from texas to new york you
get stuck in tennessee
your car keys get smashed your car's
just sitting at a gas station
and you can't get a new car key for a
week and i'm with my dog too who's like
an 80 pound pit bull
and i'm like dude what do i do and he's
like well we could just store it here so
i'm like all right well i'm not going to
stay in tennessee for like eight days
i try to get a private flight i try to
fly because you can't fly with a dog
eventually i like waited in line for
hours to get so from my point of view i
get a text message in our group chat
that's like how much does a private jet
cost
what yeah and i need to get to new york
i'm stuck here i can't get on a normal
flight because my
i have an 80 pound pit bull with me i
don't want to leave my car
but i guess i have to and how am i going
to come back and get
my car very confusing situation it was a
very confusing situation now let me tell
you a few things that i learned
and this is related to this podcast so
i've flown private once or twice i've
never paid for it it was just like a
rich guy who i went along
um so yes what i what i learned
was so we have a friend in this group
we don't have to say his name i don't
know we could or could not but anyway he
went to europe
and he sent he goes i got a hotel that
was three thousand dollars a night
for 350 and i was like what how and he
sent me
he sent us a screenshot of the email and
he emailed the general manager of hotel
and he goes hey
i'm i work at this company i'm going to
be there i don't i mean he said he
worked at this company because it's a
huge company just for clout but it
doesn't really mean anything
i'm going to be there with my fiance my
budget's 400
a knife do you have anything available i
would love it to stay in this room or
this room right and he searches for all
the five-star hotels in that area and he
just sends the same thing to all the
general managers
yes and then every once in a while they
give him a hotel so he's staying in a 3
night hotel for 350 and that got me
thinking
so i googled nashville private airport
and i was like look i want a private
flight either like right now or first
thing in the morning
uh my budget is i'm willing to spend
seven thousand dollars
do you have any airlines or do you have
any uh
pilots that want some like quick work
and they were like well like it usually
cost
fifteen thousand dollars i was like well
look you tell me what
if you have someone who has work you
tell me what's the like because like you
think like private airlines like there's
no
room to haggle but it's like they're
they're just like small businesses
and so they get me a quote and that it
ended up falling through but i realized
that you could
they're like uh you know like they
actually got another bid whatever so it
didn't work out but i realized you could
totally
haggle with these people it was so
fascinating yeah the hotel thing is
great because i feel like anybody can do
that
and uh and you know if you have a little
social media following or whatever
i know instagram influencers do this
i've never even thought about doing it i
probably still won't do it because it
sounds like it's kind of time consuming
but um
i thought that was pretty great that
little tactic that he uses i thought uh
you know
these situation when you got in a pickle
you had to get creative and um
you probably like learned a bunch of
stuff that you didn't know you know 24
hours before that and never really would
have paid attention to
had you not done that like yeah you know
what to do when you're stranded
private jets can you commission a
private jet can you hop on to somebody
else's thing like what are the other
options you know
somebody's like somebody from this
podcast or the listener was like i'll
drive your
like hey when you get your key fob i'll
drive it to you in new york if you uh
like hang out with me for 30 minutes or
something like that
yeah i i saw i i don't know what i'm
going to do my it's not going to be
the situation i don't even resolve till
tomorrow so i got to figure out what i
got to do coincidentally i have to be in
nashville for work
august 1st ish there's like a podcast
conference that hubspot wants me to go
to
right so i might fly down there and drop
but anyway crazy
uh weak but can i tell you a few things
uh i noticed when i
so i've driven and then we'll get some
we'll get to ideas but i i've drive
cross country a lot i've done it a bunch
of times i love doing long road trips in
america
and it's always fun to get out of our
little silicon valley
or new york or whatever like fancy tech
guy bubble
and a few things that like i noticed the
first
dude the average american eats so poorly
and what makes you say that well granted
i am like on the road but like i i try
to like actually go to these
small towns but man like
just seeing what i l i'll just like go
to a gas station or go to mcdonald's
or i'll go to like um a restaurant and i
you know
because i eat in the parking lot with my
dog and i'll just like sit at what
and just look at what people order and
like the lines are packed for rallies or
sonic
man people this whole healthy eating
thing that i think is popular amongst
like
affluent people i don't think it's
popular amongst all types of people and
that is crazy to me because they're just
killing themselves
you didn't see a lot of keto and
intermittent fasting on this road trip
is
what i'm hearing no man just processed
foods and i'm not like the healthiest
i mean i splurge i like diet coke and
i'll eat mcdonald's
but oh my god when you're driving you're
gonna see it's like pit stops it's like
here you stop here for gasoline you stop
here for sugar you stop here for
caffeine
and then you just repeat that loop
gasoline sugar caffeine gasoline sugar
caffeine
i'm just shocked at the i'm shocked at
just how there are very few healthy
options
it's amazing uh i just like when i would
go to like a fast food place i'm like
look dude just give me a grilled chicken
breast and like
vegetables that's all i need by the way
we had talked about vending machines
before
and um when you're talking about this
healthy eating thing i got pitched this
company
i don't think i'm gonna invest but it's
called daily blends and
what it is is basically it's a vending
machine it's a you know healthy eating
vending machine but instead of snacks
it's basically just a meal in a jar
and you push a button and it basically
gives you a jar and the jar has like a
ready-made meal inside all you got to do
is kind of like
put the dressing on top mix it up and
then you're ready to go and
um the thing i think is smart is they
are
real they're basically doing big
corporate partnerships so they're
getting into like every hospital
so like every hospital needs to be you
know should they should a hospital
really have a vending machine that's
just like
twix you know you know candy bars and
like you know red bulls or should it
actually have like
healthy options and so whether it's like
big companies big hospitals
this sort of thing i can kind of squint
my eyes and see
like obviously it depends on the food
and how that works but
you know they're able to charge way more
than a typical vending machine because
people are getting like a healthy meal
out of it
and they basically have like a central
kitchen they make all the jars and they
go stock all their vending machines in
that city
and i think this is kind of a cool idea
i'm not going to invest but
it reminds me a little bit about that
that water company
you know the like office water company
that's done really really well yeah
that's like like a billion dollar
company i forget especially the bee
yeah yeah it's something bevvy bevy's
the name of it yeah so bevy is like one
of these genius things it's like hey
does your office want like fancier water
fountain
good use a bevy and they just get
planted in every company
and then it's just like a recurring
church and the guy who uh quinn the guy
who came on to talk about
uh vending machines he said that the
thing is is that these healthy options
like the the the the honey pot is at
uh wework where you have like a eight
dollar sandwich
um but he's like basically like most of
america just wants a monster
yeah but i think i think that's fair um
but i think
the one smart thing they're doing is
they're going there's like if you just
take hospitals
and um airports and things like that
like
they kind of they're sort of incented to
have
like another option and a kind of a
better option even just from optics
point of view
and so i think you could do pretty well
just by getting prime placements through
that but anyways
yeah random tangent off of what you said
about healthy eating on a road trip
and then the last thing that i'll
mention is i am so bullish on america
over the next two years dude
um every rent-a-car place that i've gone
to
sold out like it's so hard to rent a car
right i had a friend maybe it was your
friend if someone
i don't know if you're part of the said
that they had a hitchhike in hawaii
because they couldn't get
uh a rental car they had to just like
hope someone would pick them up
um so rental cars are crazy i like to
stay at motel sometimes i'll stay at
like a
i'll range from a 30 night place to a
200 night place just like whatever i'm
in the mood for
all everything's sold out uh the roads
are packed
every convenience store is packed i'm so
bullish on america and i went and talked
to some of my staff
and uh some of my friends who are just
like average americans
they have saved a significant amount of
money over the last two years and
they're all like
i wanna i'm i wanna go buy something i
need i need i need to spend yeah what
was it after
um like the world war whatever the
roaring 20s it seems like
we might have the roaring 2020s here
where uh
people are ready to travel they're ready
to just go like kind of like max out
all their experiences after being
sheltered in place for you know a year
plus sometimes
and uh potentially saving money have you
so i like sp
went out and talked to people like like
who i know earn between 50 to like 150
a year and i was like how much money
have you saved and they're like more
than i've ever saved in la
in years and i was like what are you
gonna do and they're like i'm ready to i
want to buy a rolex or i want to buy
they want to spend right so like my
traveling lately when went to miami and
everything we saw like it just
consistently like i try to buy
a um accessories for my trip like a like
a new rack for my car
everything is out and i'm so bullish on
america over the next two years
so that's just an interesting insight
from traveling you want to talk about
ideas
yeah let's do it um all right so i think
the big one is this ncaa thing we had
touched on this briefly but basically
the law changed
that allowed college students to make
money off their name and likeness so
previously
you're a college athlete sorry i should
have said athletes
you previously you're an ncaa athlete if
you um
if you make money you lose your amateur
status you can't play your sport anymore
and you can have your scholarship sort
of like revoked even potentially if you
uh
you you uh you've run afoul of those
laws
so that changed and all of a sudden
overnight a bunch of
opportunities opened up right so this uh
this thing that was just bottled up
because of regulations and rules
all of a sudden the court got taken out
of the bottle and
you get to see what was going to happen
and so i don't know if you've paid
attention to this
but i think we should do like a mini
brainstorm on just what we see that's
interesting or
what you saw people doing yeah so can
you explain the rule because i think
that there's some stuff around it like
you can't actually can you
not make the money yet is it like put
like you can't access the funds
is there anything weird like that uh i
don't know about that i think they
they they definitely started getting
like signing contracts and getting paid
i don't know what the
uh i don't know what the nuances of the
the fine print of the law is i didn't
look into that so i had this
suite mate in college so if you google
pure sweat have you heard of pure sweat
basketball
pure sweat so this guy named drew hanlon
he's from my hometown
yeah he's the trainer like on instagram
that you always see with every nba
player yeah so that
i've known him since i was a kid and he
was my suite mate in college so i knew
him in high school
and then we went to college together and
i was i was a track and field athlete he
was a basketball player in college and
he was my suite mate
so we uh i got to know him quite well
and he'd be working on this thing called
pure sweat it started out just as like a
binder of
like paper binder full of workouts that
he would sell for like 50 to kids in the
neighborhood and then eventually he
like made a website and an app and i
don't know how successful it is but he
was always working at night in this
thing he didn't drink or he didn't party
and he was always working on pure sweat
and he eventually after college started
training uh
what's that guy like the greek freak or
whatever and then like uh yeah
brandon beale bradley beal because he's
from st louis davis
um uh zach levine yeah so he like trains
all these guys and i've always
i i wasn't close enough to ask him but i
was like i wonder how much that pays but
anyway he has this app that's like a
hundred dollars a year
and in college i like we
i was a college app division one college
athlete i wasn't like even remotely a
big deal but they make you sit to these
seminars on how you
are are allowed and are not allowed to
use your image or your name
and he was in that office all the time
because he was tr
he was wanted to make sure he was
following the rules because he had this
business
pure sweat so he couldn't sit like he i
think he was allowed to say like this is
drew hanlon from
belmont university or whatever but
anyway this guy crushes it i bet i bet
you makes five to 10 million dollars a
year off his little business
and i have a feeling and by the way do
you know that like these like
summer camps for basketball programs
that's the money maker
yeah my uh i have friends that run these
that's the money maker and these guys my
friends
they were they're get paid by the hour i
think but i think they were getting paid
like 50 to 100
an hour like something crazy and the
program makes so much money from these
camps
so what i think would what what i think
is an easy opportunity is you're going
to see
loads of little pure sweats which is
like a really simple
app that just has basketball workouts
that you pay 100 or 200
a month or a year for i have to imagine
you're going to see loads of that that's
just such an easy low hanging fruit
my best friend trevor he was a kid from
wyoming sort of like a five foot
nine on a good day white kid who
when i got to duke i had found out oh
the roommate i got randomly matched with
he's trying to walk onto the basketball
team so i'm expecting this like six
eight black dude to show up
and instead this five nine white guy
shows up from wyoming
and i'm like no no my roommate is trying
out for the basketball team i don't know
who you are but he's like no that's me
and you know this guy was kind of like a
drew hanlon type of guy
super hard worker amazing shooter you
know like whatever you would expect
so he was like the best high school
basketball player in wyoming
comes to duke and tries to walk on ended
up long story short didn't end up making
the team he was like the last guy
cut um and then you know stayed on a
sort of like water boy hoping for his
like rudy moment
and then like that never came like some
spot opened up and then they took some
other guy because his dad is like super
rich and he's a booster of the school
and they put him on the team instead and
he's like oh [__] this
but anyways in the summers what he would
do is he would go back to wyoming
and people knew him there they were like
oh you you went to duke you're uh
you're you were like a legend high
school basketball here and he would run
these camps and every single day
he would have basically like three camps
running simultaneously
each kid just pays a hundred dollars he
was underpricing it like crazy
and um you would make his whole year's
worth of money
in like a two and a half month period
and then he spent the other nine months
out of the year
just traveling around learning stuff and
then come back and do it again the next
summer because
he had that brand affinity the way that
you're talking about that local brand
affinity
so i wanted to go over a couple things i
saw happening so the first thing is
uh cameo was a winner so winners and
losers so
so cameo is a winner um all of a sudden
every athlete just put themselves up on
cameo and if you go to cameos like ncaa
page you'll see
they already cameo already has an ncaa
page yeah they already have an ncaa page
they're ready to go
and this is like you know one of the
easy ways celebrities make money there's
like
you know 17 pages of of people available
on the ncaa page
oh my god that's so funny and they're
all so cheap it's like 25
yeah right because they're like oh sweet
that's you know three meals for me on
campus here
um okay so the second is did you see
what bar stool did
yeah so bar stool um sponsored an
athlete
for gambling right so so dave portnoy i
don't know the exact story but i
was just sort of following this on
social media he goes he's like emergency
press conference
he goes on online and he just says i'm
announcing barstool athlete
what is that i have no idea and like
that was like basically his emergency
thing
and so then somebody saw some athlete
message him was like i'll be the first
bartel athlete
and he's like okay great we got this you
know like whatever some volleyball
player
girl from this college she's our first
partial athlete so he tweets it out
you know the more people start rolling
in he's like i didn't even say what this
is yet
and so then he goes he goes on on for a
second video and he goes
listen a lot of you asking how to become
a bar stool athlete
if you play division one sports and you
blink at me i will sign you
i'll send you a t-shirt you want pizza
you want campari
i don't know what's gonna happen here we
may just become the most powerful agency
in the world here
and so i actually think that like that
that legitimately could happen because
now the athletes can have lawyers they
can have agents
um that are helping them with their
brand deals and barstool
is just there they're ready to take
advantage of this they have that brand
that's super loved
amongst college athletes and so i think
they're going to do really well out of
this so i would say
they're another winner that's that that
we talked about the four levels of luck
that's level four luck where
your reputation is such that luck finds
you and so that's what's going to happen
the best athletes are going to want to
work with barstool just because of their
reputation
it's almost boring to discuss the ideas
for this because it's obvious you just
look at what
i mean it's just they're now
professional athletes almost
that anyone has but what i think is
interesting is this idea of inflections
so like there's these cultural things
that happen
well it's not sometimes it's cultural
sometimes it's political sometimes it's
technical
uh technology driven but uh mike maples
who we had on the podcast he actually
has a blog post where he talks about
inflections because i look for
inflections so it could be
everyone has an iphone so now gps is
possible or
we were able to build this technology to
making gps possible so that's a
a cultural inflection or like um you
know being gay is cool now or not cool
but it's accepted so now like
having like a gay dating app or whatever
you know like that's like a cultural
shift or weed is no longer frowned upon
that's a cultural
inflection um now there's also
regulation and political inflections
one of them being about two years ago
when telemedicine
the law changed although it's changing
back that provided a huge gap
this is a perfect example of a
regulation slash political
inflection uh and that that big
businesses are built in times like this
i'm not gonna be the one because i don't
care about this but this is the type of
inflection that we're going to look back
same with sports gambling you know those
guys have been at it for years and years
and years and it was pretty horrible
businesses i believe for a long time
something changed boom they took off
same with ufc they weren't allowed in
new york they weren't allowed here
something
changed boom they're allowed this is one
of those moments that we'll look back on
in 20 years and be like think of all the
businesses that came from that one
ruling
yeah there's a couple examples of this
so um with you know gdpr
this is the like kind of like privacy
it's the thing where you go to a website
and it says
we want we want to you know use cookies
to enhance your experience here like uh
okay accept cookies and so this is you
know a law change that happened
and then you saw companies come out of
this that were like
i think pretty pretty big companies so
um
one of them is one trust so i think one
trust is like
over 200 million in annual recurring
revenue it's probably the fastest
growing enterprise sas
company in the last 10 years and it's
basically it's gdpr compliance as a
service hey
big company you are not so the way you
set things up
is not compliant with the new laws you
can get smashed for not being compliant
here
it's going to spend your it's going to
take your team of lawyers and engineers
in your company like weeks if not months
to just understand the laws then make
the changes so that you're compliant
like we can do this for you and so one
trust uh you know already at a five
billion dollar valuation
um in less than i don't even know when
gdpr came out that's like i don't know
five years ago or something
yeah so so that's kind of like an exa
great example asano was another one this
company i wanted to invest in in that
same space
because that regulation change made that
happen another one
united health so when obamacare kicked
in
companies like i think oscar and united
health i don't know too much about this
space but what i do know is if you go
look at the stock chart
for united health it's like flat flat
flat flat
oh something happened at like 2 2009 10
range what happened oh
you know like as the as obamacare kicked
in the stock price went from like 24
a share to 400 a share now and so
uh you know that was a better investment
than amazon google
netflix whatever during the same period
of time
because they were well positioned to
take advantage of
the new law changes so one of the law
changes that i think you could take
advantage of here is
there's the obvious ideas which is great
you're an agency for
ncaa athletes like what we're talking
about barstool or your cameo right
you're a platform where they can go on
and monetize their their name and face
another one is these athletes have to
report
the deals that they're doing to their
school so you can't just do like
anything you have to report it
i can tell you what most of these
athletes are not going to do a good job
of keeping track of all their deals how
much they get paid what the date was
what the terms were and all the
collateral they're going to need to
report this and the schools are going to
need it to report it to the ncaa
so somebody who builds that back office
sort of reporting tool that underlying
infrastructure layer
um that's going to become incredibly
valuable a way to think about that is
like
carda or or angel list like these
underlying platforms that sit underneath
um the the the entrepreneur and so
that's one that's one opportunity that i
could see
taking i actually think that's the best
idea that we you've had in a long time
all right i'll stop there i won't give
you more i don't know what like the
total
addressable market is for that but like
i mean it's enough
uh well just i mean for what's happening
right now by the way
universities to spend tens of thousands
a year for your software like that's
it's
there's enough and you'll be sticky
right and you become the system of
record
for all these things they're not going
to want to switch two years in because
this other system of record has a new
feature
so whoever gets plugged in as the system
of record has the opportunity to like
own that data
you're you're entrenched in all these
universities who are not looking to
take a bunch of risk and then you could
build on all the add-on services
so you can build on other things that
allow you know whether it's banking or
it's
contracts or it's uh marketplace for
deals whatever you can build all that on
top of the data
records record book you know what i just
realized
now this company that you and i invested
in there's actually a lot of competitors
but we invested in this company called
stan yes um
i don't even know the url it's like stan
dot me
stand with dot me and basically what it
is is you um
you put a link in your twitter bio or
your linkedin bio you click that link
and it's like link tree where you see
like five different pages you can click
off to but it says like
book a call with me sell you this thing
it's basically for commerce you know
like giving you money for an exchange
for some type of you know whether it's
time or document
perhaps we'll see those type although i
don't necessarily believe that that will
be the case but
um this thing might like impact that
business but so i think there's a bunch
of
cool inflections here um and this whole
like idea of inflections i think
there's a lot to learn from i was just
reading about thomas edison and
basically he was like look i just
invented this light bulb
it's gonna work it's amazing but there
was no power at the time and he's like
well we can power it by putting up these
these wires that go from house to house
to house and the government was like no
we're not doing this and so one day he
uh hosts a dinner and he goes i want all
you guys to come to this dinner
and they come up to the dinner and
there's no lamps so it's pitch black
and they're sitting there they're like
what the hell are we doing and then he
just flips a switch and boom his lights
come on automatically and there's
waiters there
ready to greet them and they're like and
he's like this is how people are gonna
live from now on
and they go oh great okay fine we'll we
will allow
you to uh put electricity throughout
manhattan in the smaller area to test it
out
and so this idea of and that is how by
the way i got chills while you're
telling that story i love that
and that is how uh ge came to be
eventually was
uh in a bunch of these companies uh that
thomas edison had on
uh you know he was involved in a little
bit of everything and so anyway
until you tweet something that thomas
edison invented the word hello
yeah so basically before edison people
would say greetings or
good afternoon like hello wasn't even a
word in fact the word hello
it was pronounced a little bit
differently it was like how low or like
something silly like that
and when he invented the phone he was
actually
partially deaf and also the phones
weren't very good so he would call like
an operator in order to set this up and
they would have to
think of a word to say to be like the
greeting on the phone and he was like
well
the word hello i can actually stream
that pretty easily
and so i'm gonna start saying hello like
it was hello
it was like originally it was meant to
like as a
as a word to like say oh you surprised
me hello you surprised me you know
uh and so that's how he started saying
it and then once people started using
the phone they started saying it and the
phone got better and then it just became
a
hello wow and that's that's how the word
hello came to be
and then anyway this idea of inflections
are actually really interesting so
there's all types of moments where these
things are capable and i think that
this ncaa thing it's interesting the
idea you said is interesting
but the concept here of inflections is
actually more important because we're
actually seeing it happen right now
and by the way i hear this so often um
two two examples come to mind one i was
talking to
um this guy jesse poojie who we should
have on the podcast i know him he
lives in st louis that's right and he
was telling me his story
you know oh how did you build your
company he built this company ampush it
was like this digital marketing agency
that was working with
dollar shave club and blue apron and all
the big brands and so
and they eventually sold it and so one
of the things he had said he's like yeah
you know we were just doing this other
thing and it was kind of wasn't working
and then that's when uh you know like
that's when whatever
the facebook platform launched um or
facebook announced
you know news feed or google launched
adwords or whatever right there's all
these like
moments where a new thing comes into
existence he's like
well like this thing we're doing is not
working so like let me go jump on that
and um and the same story is true for
for
uh our friend sully who he was like yeah
i quit my job at microsoft i wanted to
go be an entrepreneur i didn't know what
i was going to do
so i um i moved back in to my parents
house
and like that day that i moved in i was
you know just browsing the internet and
i saw that
facebook launched this new platform app
platform so i was like okay cool like
let me try to build an app today
and he's like i didn't know if it was
gonna be a thing but like he was one of
the first app developers on there built
a simple
dumb app and like immediately started to
like go
to fly on facebook because facebook was
that good of a like
uh platform and it was so new that
people wanted to play with the new thing
on the platform
and so that was like their start and
i've really heard this a bunch of times
which is
a lot of times as an entrepreneur you
just need to be
in the market you need to be in the game
and even if your current thing's not
working
if you are aware of these like
inflection points these shifts these
platform shifts
or or big changes either in law or
technology or
uh open platforms things like that
you're you're the perfect person to just
shift over because you're kind of like
already jogging
you're not at like a cold start you're
not like at a job where you got to
decide if i should quit or not
and um and you weren't so successful at
your current thing that you're
that you're married to it so you hop on
over and i've just heard this many many
times over this same
um same model of like yeah i was just
doing this thing it wasn't really
working that great
and then boom i saw that facebook ad
platform launched so i made an ad for
t-shirts and i started selling like
crazy and then i started you know then
you know
those are the glory days and it's all
downhill from there but and we are
seeing
we're seeing these actually constantly
so um like there's a thousand examples
that we can just give that just happened
in the last five or ten years i mean you
said facebook you said google you said
you could say the same for snapchat
clubhouse likely won't pan out but that
was definitely an opportunity to have
one
this ncaa thing the medical thing where
now doctors could practice uh remotely
because kovid i mean
working remotely i mean there's just
they happen constantly what i like to do
is i like to read politico
politico is a cool site that tells you
on regulation updates
that's a great way to learn about these
um but there's like loads of different
inflections and they happen consistently
and you
you could be an insider to have to see
some of them so like you know if you're
not working
in tech you're not going to see like the
the power of facebook early on
but like a lot of them are actually like
the the information is
oftentimes blatantly obvious it's not
obvious that this is going to be the one
but it's blatantly obvious like
all right this could be a inflection
right yeah and it goes back to that same
two by two matrix uh this athlete thing
is
um is basically its new problem
like all of a sudden a whole bunch of
people have a new problem these athletes
have to keep track of their records they
want to make money they can now do this
and there's going to be old you know you
can take some old solution and repurpose
it for
for this new opportunity this new
problem that that exists in the world
and so
all right let's move on let's do another
one uh do you have one or you want me to
do yeah
so um i just found this company and i
actually heard of it for a while
i'll tell you two interesting companies
that i i discovered
um the first one it was it's called
nera.com before this it was called fyi
i think yes um so the reason why i
came i i found this do you know who
heaton shy is
i know he shot yeah i invested in euro
by the way oh you did
yeah oh sick all right well we could
talk about it so heat and shock
so there's this guy named neil patel
who's like the face and if you are
probably a little bit younger than me
then you probably don't know who he is
but if you're about my age or older
you probably know who who neil patel is
he had this amazing blog called
quicksprout and this was like if you
wanted to learn anything about search or
google
his blog for somehow i don't know how he
managed this
covered pretty much everything and he
built a huge blog for seo and it became
a huge business and he launched
loads of different software products on
top of it well heaton shaw was his
uh right-hand man and probably the
operator behind the brains behind this
he just launched this new business a
while ago
and i had i looked at my old messages i
dm'd him two years ago when he first
launched it but i didn't have any money
at the time
and i was like dude this is amazing and
so he changed the name to nira
and it's really simple what it is is
basically if you are a company like
hubspot so you have 30 or 3000 employees
or the hustle when we had just 10
employees even when you have 10
employees my current gmail has a 100
gigs full so let's say you do times 10
that's
a thousand gigs that's like a terabyte i
believe of data
that's like hundreds of thousands of
documents and images and
whatever it's really hard to find all of
those images
but also it's hard to know who has
access to all these things so for
example
you have this document called salaries
and you must have like accidentally said
like share to everyone who has access to
this
to this folder you don't [__] see
that or if someone quits they still have
access to
this document called passwords like
stupid stuff yep
well heaton built this software that i
didn't even realize this was a problem
i mean i have had this problem but i'm
like oh this is actually a great thing
that you could sell
it was a blind spot you're just like oh
this is just the way the world is
you know it's just like a problem you
live with until somebody says by the way
you know you can
you could stop that right yeah yeah yeah
and so he's been working on but here's
so so anyway it's
the the product is is interesting but
that's not even what i care about
it's basically just a search engine for
an entire company's documents
well that okay so that's what it
originally was that's the f1 that's what
fyi was which was like a quick way you
just type in you don't need to know that
the doc is in like normally
you want to find a doc you think oh
that's in google drive or that's in
dropbox or
uh maybe it's an asana or so i need to
go find this thing so what he made was
just like one search bar to go find
the document across all your cloud apps
and i think
you know after a bunch of trial and
error and customer development you found
out that that's not the problem we're
solving
the problem we're solving is that second
part you talked about which is the
security if you go to nero.com it's just
it just says protect your company
documents from unauthorized access
which is exactly what it says like says
that's the problem you were talking
about right like
i just brought somebody on board and
they were showing me
um you know like a spreadsheet from a
previous company that they worked at
and i was like you still have access to
this and he's like yeah i don't know
like i'm not obviously i'm not doing
anything bad with it but like yeah it's
so [__] up you shouldn't have that you
know that's like their kpis
um and i'm guilty of this too like you
said like you share one thing with an
even with a group or a list and now they
have a bunch of stuff
or somebody leaves and they shouldn't
have it or you're sharing it with some
vendor
and like that vendor still has access
and it it is impossible
to go through all your documents that
are in the cloud
and make sure that who has the right
thing and so nera is solving that
problem by creating like one interface
works so i think that's kind of a like a
pretty genius
uh problem like a problem that they
identified that's worth solving
i think every this is a every company
problem uh as far as i'm concerned
and only growing but i want to explain
why first of all how did you hear about
this
because your friends at heaton he
hollered at you yeah loosely
he uh we're not dead but he's like we're
cool with each other and then i saw this
i was like oh that's dope
how did you see how are you know all
this see i'm friends with him and he
like
i hope we talk and so i saw he was
talking about there
oh my god that's so funny you're you're
in on everything um
he uh but there's a few things that's
interesting first of all like
i'm pretty positive this has i mean he
could screw it up
and and i mean like there's execution
risk here but i think like it's going to
be pretty big like if as long as i just
have c
plus execution but what is interesting
to me
is and this is out of my world you know
you and i do stuff that we come up with
an idea and we can make money off of it
in five days but it can also like go
away pretty easily
he's been working on this for two years
before is getting any customers with
like
10 employees because in order to sell
these enterprise contracts
especially to the i.t department where
everyone's like up tight as they should
be
you have to everything's got to be
buttoned up and it's really cool that i
get intel or insight into that because i
normally don't ever see that
you have to have so much patience to
build these sas tools and so i don't
think i'm cut out for it but
i thought it was really interesting
specifically the enterprise ones right
there's two types of sas there's like
bottoms up
where it's just like kind of like
consumer like oh you just have this cool
product a developer hears about you pm
hears about you they just sign up
themselves and
you're hoping it kind of spreads virally
throughout the the company
because the product is so good it's
product driven growth and then there's
enterprise sales and enterprise sales is
basically saying i need to go be able to
knock on
knock on the doors of people the right
people at the top of a company
i need to be able to sell a product for
over a hundred thousand dollars a year
eventually
and um and that's my that's my game and
i'm gonna the sales cycle might be
six to eighteen months and i'm gonna do
what i can to accelerate that but in
reality that's just the way these
companies move
and i'm with you that that is not the
dna i have that's not where i would be
that's not where i would be strong but
other people you know who do it
obviously enterprise sales is like
extremely valuable when you can when you
can do it yeah so i just wanted to bring
this up because
it was interesting to like talk to him
and be like yeah we're working for two
years
doing this our road map is this and that
is just
not really what we talk about a lot of
like this like epic planning and like
really
like all right in three years hopefully
we'll be here uh
next in two quarters we'll be at this
and i actually think that that's good i
i wish i were like that a little bit i'm
not
uh but i thought it was crazy
fascinating to see
how you have to sweat the details so
much before you even get a customer and
you just
spend so much money right you know 10 20
engineers to do this
so i just wanted to bring that up you
want to do another one yeah let's do one
um i think i've said this once before on
the pod but i want to do
i'll do it quickly you tell me if we've
already talked about it but it's this
idea of
zapier for sounds have i talked do you
know which idea i have here
you didn't bring it up last time but i
i've heard this phrase before from you i
don't think you brought it up
you were the one who kind of really
highlighted zapier to me right i was
using it
and zapier for all i knew might have
just been like two dudes
you know who built this as a side
project and they're kind of in
they're on andy hackers.com
bootstrapping and they're at you know 8
000 a month of mrr
no zapier is like a billion dollar
company multi-billion dollar
multi-billion dollar company that was
largely bootstrapped i think i think
they they got they raised a million
dollars in funding and used that million
dollars in funding to get to
a billion dollar status right so so
pretty freaking impressive
when you go to the product it's like a
very simple thing zapier just lets you
say hey it's like a pipe so it just
connects two different services so you
might say
hey whenever somebody signs up for my on
my website for my mailing list
put them into this spreadsheet or like
send me an email
um and so you're just connecting like
gmail and your your website or you're
connecting like
whatever shopify and slack so you just
connect you just create these little
formulas if this
happens then do this and so that's what
zapier is
and zapier's become very very successful
obviously because people want that they
they want to say okay they want to
basically nobody wants to build anything
it's like there's a million there's a
tool for everything but
they don't speak to each other so the
xavier is like a connector between tools
so anyways xavier for sounds what is it
so my friend
um samir had this idea and uh smirbala
and he
was gonna do it and then he like found a
better opportunity
like there's a fast-growing startup and
he joined as like a exec there instead
um and i was like oh dude i love this
idea and i agreed for like
i put like a one and a half year embargo
on talking about this idea
because i thought he might do it at this
point i'm pretty confident he's not
going to do it
but the visioning outline was pretty
damn good he goes
every team every company has something
in there some event that happens in
their company that they celebrate
for the hustle it might be getting an
email subscriber maybe it's getting a
new advertiser to come on board or
selling a trend subscription
and um like wouldn't it be great if
there was just a sound right the old
kind of like
and in most offices there's like a gong
i bet you guys had a gong or your sales
yeah you have a gong you have a gong you
literally you go you make a sale you
stand up you walk to the gong you
grab the thing and you hit it and
everybody knows boom the good thing has
happened
and in our office we used to manually
wire this up we built a charity product
and every time somebody donated it would
go cha-ching on the like speakers in the
office
and you would do that until it gets too
annoying and then you kind of turn it
off
if it gets like too frequent and so i
really like this idea of basically
taking any
service you have maybe it's stripe maybe
it's your email list maybe it's uh your
your um your bank account whatever and
um
and anytime the good you just basically
create these formulas you say if this
good thing happens
play this sound play it on my phone
that's like essentially like a ringtone
and you know or play it on my sonos
speakers or whatever in my office
and so the cool thing that you could do
with this is i think that's a pretty
simple problem and i think people will
like that they'll be able to hook it up
but it actually gets pretty
sophisticated because you can't what you
can't do is you can't
say like hey you know what at the
beginning notify me about everything and
then
as it gets more mature what you really
want is to say hey when we get if we hit
100 subscribers today
play that sound i want to know when we
hit 100 for the day right because every
everyone now it's too annoying it's too
frequent
so let me set this better rule so
there's nothing that lets you set those
rules so i think there's a very simple
company to build here
that's zapier for sounds that could be a
sas company that
you know i think it could do a few
million dollars a year but maybe it's
more like zapier maybe
this is a bigger problem than i would
have otherwise expected and could get
into the tens of millions or even 100
million dollars
of revenue just celebrations as a
service what do you think
all right what my reply is going to
sound like a tangent but it's not
so again i'm on this edison kick i'm
reading all about him
and in the biography when he created the
phonograph so basically a record player
people are like why are you wasting your
time on this stupid toy
like this is not interesting this is not
going to help anyone this is so dumb
this looks janky
and obviously it wasn't right it changed
the world and
uh it was the first time that anyone had
ever heard requ
someone's voice before besides you know
just talking
and a lot of really cool ideas that
great people have or ideas that turn out
to be amazing whether it's airbnb or
uber they sound like these stupid dumb
things
you're actually particularly good at
finding things that
are toys or silly on the surface
and making the case for why this can
actually be huge and big
and you're because you kind of default
to optimism what is your default to
optimism and how this could be big
because my default is
this is such a silly i'm i'm i recognize
that i default to that but
although i'm trying not to my default is
this is just a what like what that's
such a small silly thing
tell me everything uh yeah i think it
probably is a small silly thing but i
like
things that for sure can win at the
small scale
and there's a hey who knows a path that
you can go down because i think most
things that end up quite big um they
typically will start with
what looks like a kind of humble humble
level of ambition right facebook it's a
college network for
harvard and then oh maybe it's it's a
social network for
all colleges and then it becomes now
you know they literally just start
building this like internet pipe in
africa
to basically bring bring internet to
more people in africa so more people can
use facebook right like
their ambition was progressively growing
there's interviews of
zuck early on when they're like oh are
you gonna expand to high schools
he's like no i don't know i mean like
does it have to it could just be a cool
college thing right that was zuck then
and zuck now is like
you know let me take over the the
universe and so i think i like
ideas like this that that will start
small the thing that gives me
hope that this might be big bigger than
you think is
every single company i know wants to
celebrate their wins and morale goes up
when you celebrate your wins
and so if you can come up with simpler
ways
to celebrate progress i think it'll make
happier companies and i think that
managers will want that
want that option or want to be able to
configure that option so that
um yeah everybody feels a sense of
progress everybody
feels a sense of of a boost as you know
like you used to say
every email we're a pirate ship and
every email subscriber is a little bit
of wind in our in our sales right
so how do you make it actually feel like
that versus just
sitting in every day in the office and
only focusing on all the problems and
all the things that are broken
i actually think that uh there's a great
lesson here
i didn't used to think about this way
when i was a little bit younger and now
i'm
i'm changing but i remember when i first
started
creating stuff and i see a lot of people
who are early in their career of
creating stuff they think like
uh the market's like too saturated like
no one buys
courses or uh you know there's already
like
ads no one clicks ads but what you
actually just did was interesting is you
looked at the macro like the
the high level like human beings do
want this so you so the way that you
just described it you goes
you go everyone i know all companies
want to celebrate
a win like we all know celebrating a win
is first for
is great we also know that a lot of them
celebrate a win
with a sound therefore it actually is
plausible that this could be interesting
and i think that that's far more
productive and helpful
than starting the other way around so
for example i would justify a course
like we all know that people want to
learn how to do this
and we also know that a lot of people
buy stuff so like it's pretty
justifiable that if i execute well
people will buy this
and that's like an easy way to like back
yourself into like of course this can
succeed
it can succeed a lot i don't know but
and i think that that's actually a
really interesting way that you tend to
look at things
um and that's cool that's cool all right
let's do
one more uh one more idea right now do
you have one or you want me to do one
i could tell you one and um i don't want
to make this all about stuff that i'm
investing in but
so i i will disclose i am an investor in
this but i actually
am not entirely sold on the idea i'll
say that so click that website
stake dot rent okay i'm on it so let me
just tell you what i see first reaction
it says
cash back for rentals is here pay your
rent
and get cash back at a home or office
that offers stake okay so
what does that mean okay so there's this
guy
i don't even know his name i barely
talked to him but he created the rewards
program
for amex and a couple other airlines
and so these reward programs they give
you stuff in order to make you happier
so you want to stay with amex so
uh discounts to stuff uh in order
you know when you sign up for amex you
you get a discount for movie tickets or
on your insurance
and so he was thinking and this guy
knows nothing about real estate i don't
i don't think so
um and he was like we should actually do
this for rent and when you think about
it a lot of actually
renters or or landlords actually do this
so they say
i'm gonna give you a month's free or two
months free have you seen signs for that
yeah
especially to start your lease yeah yeah
so it's very common so they're already
doing that and he was like you know
if you give someone one month free
that's 8.3
of annual rents that you're giving
someone a year right if instead
you made it so you get three or four or
five percent
cash back every month that you pay your
rent on time
that's actually kind of an interesting
way to build loyalty amongst the renter
and
it's like a smaller you know it's like a
gold stock like sometimes
sean might be happier if i give him a
gold star versus like giving him a
hundred dollars
right you know what i mean okay that's
interesting and so the math i mean
three percent every month would add up
to more than eight for the year so how
does the math work is it like more like
one percent cash back basically or what
yeah it it
it's a smaller fee i i don't know what
th what the exact fee but you it's
usually less than
it's like less than six percent a year
um and so it's something like twenty
dollars a month
but it and they get the money if they
pay the rent on time and they're busy
they're proving to the landlord hey look
if i give if i help your renter if i
if your renter feels like i'm getting a
bonus for paying my rent on time every
month
uh i will lower the i will lower your
your sort of defaults and your
uh late payments uh on rent by expert
just a little bit
yeah if they can show that one behavior
then they can go to every landlord and
say the same thing
that's the idea exactly and i thought
that was kind of interesting and the
reason why i thought was interesting is
there's actually a few things i don't
i don't care about the stake dot rent
whatever who cares what
there's a few things interesting here
one what i like is a guy
with no experience in real estate but
experience with human behavior
being around loyalty and looking at
different places to apply that that
intrigues me
um i lost my train of thought but but
that's really interesting to me oh
and the second thing is when i heard
this idea i'm like well this is like
this doesn't seem like a groundbreaking
idea like this seems shockingly obvious
and easy to pull off
why isn't anyone doing this part of me
was like well if no one's doing it
there's a reason why
no one has done it right yeah like
that's one side of things but the other
side of things is like maybe this
isn't the right outsider so i thought
this was like an interesting idea do you
think that this this can work
uh yeah i think this could work i i
think it's hard because
if you it depends on your world view
like the first time i heard about
um what's it called layaway you know you
know about layaway
and this yeah i mean it doesn't really
exist much anymore it doesn't sound like
privileged
i think it exists i think it exists in a
big way still so i think at like
um you know i think it was more popular
years and years and years ago like when
i my dad used to tell me all the time
when he was a kid he would do layaway
right so so basically layaway i i didn't
know about this but basically let's say
you go to a walmart
and um you go to walmart you want to buy
something you don't want you don't have
the money to pay the whole thing
you basically say i want to put this on
layaway and you it's
what i thought was going to happen is
it's more like those uh you know buy now
pay later type of things where it's like
um you have to keep it yeah like it's
like a firm or something like that where
you
you buy the thing and instead of paying
the whole hundred dollars up front you
make four payments of 25 bucks
and you you pay it over time but you get
your thing from day one with layaway
from what i understand it's the exact
opposite
layaway you just put the thing on hold
there
and then you come back every month and
start making your payments until you own
the thing
so it's like kind of like it's like
doing a chore in a way right it's like
it's like telling your parent hey if
like i will i will work hard for four
straight months in order to get this
thing and so this is apparently like a
very big i should have looked this up i
didn't know we're going to talk about it
but
uh layaway is actually like a pretty
huge part of like the economy
especially in in like kind of like lower
end retail like walmarts and stuff
and so um so i thought that was kind of
interesting and and it got me thinking
about like
all these little like incentive
structures around paying for things
so what you're talking about is
incentive structure for uh rent
there's other incentives around rent i
don't know if you've seen have you seen
rhino
it's like a rent uh service basically
you pay your rent
and you build your credit by paying yeah
i love those i
i i wanted to do one of it so it's
sayrino.com
i wanted to use one of them because for
years my credit was only okay because i
didn't have credit but i'm like
it's [__] that your rent doesn't
count as credit yeah so so
i don't know if that's what reina does
but some people do that then then what
rhino is doing is they're basically like
they looked at
when most people when you go rent a
place you put the first or the first and
second month's rent down as a deposit
and they're like dude that means there's
like x hundreds of millions or billions
of dollars
that are just deposits that are just
locked away
and so um and so so basically what they
created i think was like an insurance
product that said hey you don't have to
pay
you don't have to pay your you don't
have to put a thousand dollars down as
your deposit
instead you pay five dollars a month as
an insurance policy and we will
we will cover the landlord if the
deposit ever kicks in
and you get to keep your money instead
of putting down thousands of dollars as
a deposit and having that dead money
just locked away for a while
and i thought that was i think that's
what rhino does now but there's all
these like
interesting things around either real
estate incentives another one i want to
tell you about
is smile.io have you ever seen this
probably not
it's more of an e-commerce thing but i'm
right now i'm in the process of
designing like a loyalty program
and um so when you when you said this
thing about the guy who did it for amex
that's interesting because i was just
researching amex as loyalty like the
psychology of these programs
let me read it so smile dot io turn your
hard earned sales into repeat customers
maximize your customer acquisition
efforts and turn transactional sales
into passionate brand advocates i don't
really know what that means
so do this instead go to this website
and just look at the bottom left where
it says
uh where it says give 10 get 10. give 10
get 10.
um well i see three for 40 at the bottom
left
see there's a little pop-up that says 10
get 10. so
in this is two things so this is powered
by smile.io so basically what smile. is
they're going to e-commerce stores and
they say hey
you should have a loyalty program you
should have a referral program just like
starbucks
and amex and these companies that spend
millions of dollars and
thousands of hours fine-tuning and
designing this thing we'll just make it
like
a shopify app for you and so what does
the shopify app
do so basically you go on and it's like
you want a referral program cool
here's the thing that will be on your
site so any customer who comes in they
know that if i share this with a friend
and they get a discount so created a
two-way reward system
the second thing is if you scroll down
there's like a little like
points program in this case it's called
bubbles um but but
the points program basically says here's
how you earn points
you follow us on instagram you like our
stuff you buy
you for every dollar you spend in the
store you get five points um
tell us your birthday well if you if you
create a birthday we'll give you 500
points
uh write a review you get 200 points so
they incentivize all these behaviors
that you know
leads to a stickier customer and in
doing so they get points that they can
redeem for free [__] in the store
like store credit basically and so all
of that like reward system magic
they just make available and easy for
any e-commerce store right so
then it sounds a bit like infomercial
but really i don't i have no skin in the
game here i just
think it's a sick product but i love the
idea of basically
taking like what the big brands do and
what the big brands have spent millions
of dollars developing for themselves
and then just turning that into an app
that any little mom and pop can just
plug into their store and have that same
user experience
and so i've seen this as a trend as a
business like kind of like model
blueprint
i told you about that company i invested
in joe coffey they did the same thing
they took the starbucks mobile app
which was like super slick made it easy
to order on your phone
you earn stars for everything that you
buy and they basically give any
mom and pop coffee shop a white label
version of that same app called joe
coffee
and so now you can have order ahead you
can have loyalty points you can have
push notification marketing
you have all the things that starbucks
put like probably tens of millions of
dollars into building
they just made for and they said good
we're going to arm the rebels we're
going to give this to
all of the indie coffee shops instead of
just what just starbucks having it
because they can afford the r d
this is sick i uh yeah this is sick
i'm looking at it now uh does this work
have you
implemented this like when i see these
um
rewards programs or things like that
like when i go to a lot of ecomm sites
uh there's like a wheel that you spin
and if you enter in your email
you get something like there's all these
like tricks and
we put we went from normal and pretty
looking thing that says hey you know
give us your email for a discount code
to the wheel it tripled conversion rate
tripled so have you implemented this
club tub
i just uh started working on this last
night to to implement it but i'm like
i'm figuring out what are the perks
because you have to find the balance
right if you give too much value away it
eats all your margins
and if you make it too shitty then
nobody's motivated to do anything you
wasted your time
you got to find the sweet spot where
it's like compelling enough to them
and it doesn't eat away your margins and
that's the
sort of like that's the art of this um
of doing it but i love that i can do
this without knowing how to code
i think that's kind of like you know a
great business model
an idea and so i would do that if i
wanted to think of other ideas like this
i would just go look at
what do the top retailers like i'd go to
starbucks i go to lululemon i would go
to
you know whoever macy's uh nordstrom
and i would walk around i would use
their online shop and i would walk
around their store and i would say
what have they built that's custom and
awesome for them and then how can i make
the white label version of that and
offer it to every other retailer that's
competing with them
there's this great thing i want to bring
up basically
i don't know where i heard about it but
at facebook chamath or someone
early on discovered that there's like
the magic number of seven
um i basically if you create a facebook
account
we need you to add seven friends right
away and if you add seven
friends you're likely to become a
facebook user forever or for a long
period you know what i'm talking about
yes basically they've said the aha
moment meaning
aha moment when we talk about product
building is just like
a user comes to your site they don't
know what the [__] going on they're
kind of confused they're trying to sign
up
and finally there's an aha moment where
they get actual value from the product
they're like oh
you know like if i go to mint.com the
aha moment is seeing all my financials
you know like laid out in front of me in
my budget and my pie chart oh wow
automatically that's the aha moment for
mint you got to do a whole bunch of [__]
connect a whole bunch of bank accounts
and credit cards
to get to that but when you're there
you're sticky for facebook what they
found was
seven friends in 10 days was the aha
moment so
once you saw seven different friends on
your feed and if you could do that
within 10 days
you were like super super sticky so at
the hustle we found
i don't remember the numbers off the top
of my head but we found like if you open
five out of seven days right off in the
first seven
five times the first seven you're gonna
be with us and we're gonna call you a
gold person
right and so uh whatever and we have
this new thing called snippets where
we're trying to automate a lot of the
email content and you sign up for the
hustle and you tell us what type of news
you care about and we automatically like
give you a customized email
and what we're seeing is that the people
who fill that information in and it's
like a relatively long flow
they are like three or four times more
engaged than
other people right and a debate that i
have
and i'm bringing this back to what we're
talking about is that i actually think
the question is like
were those people more likely to become
power users anyway and they are filling
that out
or are they becoming power users because
they fill that out
and i would argue it was the second one
so
like if someone's gonna give what's this
tub huh whatever this would
become whatever we're talking about yeah
if the are they going to
become are they power users already and
so they're more likely to give you your
email and like you on instagram i would
actually say no
because you were there going through
this little small indoctrination process
they are now becoming power users it's
like what are you are you confident
therefore you're going to flex your
muscles or do you flex your muscles and
then become feel like you are confident
right and so i actually think that
making users
do this stuff you are turning them into
power users
yeah i mean it's true too i think
there's an element of both i think that
the people who are already power users
are gonna be like oh my god my favorite
thing has more value i can go get like
let me go do it
and then there's a whole bunch of other
people that are potential power users
if the circumstances were right if they
followed you so then they would see your
updates
if they gave you their email so that you
could show them the new stuff blah blah
blah then
then you're gonna get more uh you're
going to higher likelihood of turning
that casual person
into a hardcore person and so i think i
think both do happen
do you want to save this you want to
wrap up now and save some of the stuff
for next week
yeah actually i just want to say two
more examples of the same trend so um
the the same trend if you go and look at
the hustle's emails
uh you guys have at the bottom like a a
survey thing it's like were you happy
medium or sad from the ceo you have an
ambassador program
and a lot of those were like things you
either you got off the shelf and
modified or you just built homegrown
and so if you're a newsletter if you're
if you want to build something for the
newsletter industry
go look at what the hustle go look at
what you know axios or what these guys
are all using
and be like cool how do i give every
newsletter the ability to just have this
feature without
um without having to build it themselves
because clearly it's working
and they're competing with groups like
the hustle that are like
years ahead have employees have money to
be able to spend on this type of stuff
yeah and we did have to build a lot of
that by the way and it was horrible and
it breaks all the time and like it's i
would wave
like a lot of people a lot of people who
there's this whole there's a large
contingency of people who say oh let's
build our own stuff
a lot of people who have been there done
that will say the exact opposite which
is
never build anything if you don't have
to always use off the shelf
right i fall into that category and
i wish i wish a lot of the stuff had
existed i'd rather pay a software fee
than an engineer
and you talked about this once you were
talking about paywall software you're
like yeah i'm in the media business and
like
the best sites have really good smart
paywalls that convert
and then the rest of us are using this
kind of like crappier version of that
like why don't we all
let's just pretend and say the new york
times has the best paywall
flow that's causing highest conversion
rates somebody should take that and just
say
do you want the new york times payroll
on your site great here's new york times
paywall as a service
an example another example in this trend
is um slice
so basically domino's had the best uh
pizza ordering experience it's like you
would order the pizza on your phone
then it would show you the progress bar
it's like oh you know like
you know john has put it in the oven uh
you're 20 minutes
oh it's out of the oven we're just
putting the toppings on top oh it's in
the car it's almost near you
hey it's at your door and so like you
know they spent a lot of money doing
that because they're dominoes they can
afford that
and what slice did was slice went to
every indie poppy
indie pizza shop and basically gave them
an app that was
the domino's mobile ordering experience
and said hey now you can compete
against that so let's just compete on
the basis of whose pizza is the best
rather than well they made it so easy
and fun to order and
mine still is like call me and i'll
write it down on a piece of paper
um and they became a billion dollar
company doing that
in that space it's the same model that
when you see three or four versions of
these
that's the pattern recognition to say
okay that's a that's a blueprint i can
follow to get a new business idea
i agree and we want to wrap up there
yeah let's wrap up this one and then uh
yeah all right we uh that's the episode
holler
let's travel never looking back